Every day, it seems to me at the moment,
there are crazy claims and headlines,
not just in AI, but in the wider world.
So, this video is going to attempt to
debunk a few of those headlines and just
give you what we know. Going to look at
Llama 4, the model that has been a year
in the waiting and has many claims and
counter claims about it. Then the blog
post/paper from a former OpenAI
researcher that has millions and
millions of views online and was
featured in the New York Times
essentially predicting super
intelligence by 2027. Then some very
recent news about the release date of
what could be the smartest model of them
all along with a ton of contradictions
about whether and when it might come
out. I just simply can't resist starting
out with a quote which could dampen
literally all the hype that you see in
AI. When Dario Ammedday, the CEO of
Anthropic, makers of the Claude series
of models, was asked what could stop AI?
What could stop the progress? He
mentioned a war in Taiwan, which we've
known is a risk for a long time. I
highly recommend the book Chip Wars by
Chris Miller. He then briefly touched on
there being a potential data wall where
they run out of highquality data to
train their models on. But then he
touched on a new risk that he hadn't
mentioned before. And before you hear
this quote, note that it came 3 weeks
ago before all of this tariff craziness.
What are the top three things that could
stop the show? If there's a large enough
disruption to the stock market that
messes with the capitalization of these
uh companies, basically a kind of belief
that the technology will not, you know,
move move forward and that kind of
creates a self-fulfilling prophecy where
there's there's not enough
capitalization. I just want to spend 30
seconds on explaining how that might
play out. Companies like OpenAI and
Anthropic need to raise money to fund
those vast training runs that go behind
their latest models. They don't just
have 40 billion or 100 billion sitting
around in their bank account to fund
those vast data centers and everything
else that goes into training a language
model. The trouble is, of course, if
investors don't think they'll get their
money back, perhaps due to a recession,
then they either won't invest in these
companies or invest less at lower
valuations. Less money means less
compute, which means slower AI progress.
That's not a prediction, of course. No
one, including myself, knows what's
going to happen. It's just easy to
forget that AI operates in the real
world and real world things can have
consequences for AI progress. And
speaking of AI progress, how much
progress is represented by the release
of Llama 4 and two of the three models
in the Llama 4 family? Well, it's hard
to be exact because as ever, there's a
lot more spin than honest analysis in
the release of this family, but it seems
like not too much. There's no paper, of
course, that's starting to become the
norm. But here are the highlights of
what we do know. First, the smallest of
the Llama 4 models has what they call an
industry-leading context window of 10
million tokens. Think of that being
around 7 1/2 million words. That sounds
insane, of course, and innovative, but
two quick caveats. All the way back to
February 2024, we had a model Gemini 1.5
Pro that had a 10 million token context
window. And with that extreme window, it
could perform amazing needle in a
haystack recovery on videos and audio
and text. In public at least, we quote
only got models of up to 2 million
tokens of context window, though perhaps
because Google realized something. They
realized perhaps that it's all well and
good finding individual needles in a
haststackag as demonstrated in this
llama 4 blog post. If you dump in all
the Harry Potter books and drop in a
password, say halfway through, the model
will be able to find it and retrieve it.
But most people, let's be honest, aren't
sneaking in passwords into seven volumes
of Harry Potter. So these results from
the release 48 hours ago seem less
relevant to me than this updated
benchmark from 24 hours ago. It's called
fiction livebench for long context, deep
comprehension. This is the benchmark
where language models have to piece
together plot progressions across tens
or hundreds of thousands of tokens or
words. In my last video on Gemini 2.5
Pro, I noted it's extremely good
performance on this benchmark. In
contrast, for Llama 4 for the mediumsiz
model and the smallest model,
performance is pretty bad and gets
worse. The numbers at the top refer to
the clues being strewn across, say 6,000
words or 12,000 words or even 100,000
words. Things then get stranger when you
think about dates. Why was Llama 4
released on a Saturday? That is
unprecedented in the entirety of the
time I've covered AI. If you were going
to be vaguely conspiratorial, you would
think that they released it on a weekend
to sort of dampen down attention. Also
note that its knowledge cutoff is August
2024. That's the most recent of the
training data that Llama 4 was trained
on. Compare that to Gemini 2.5, which
has a knowledge cutoff of January of
2025. Kind of hints to me that Meta were
trying desperately to bring this model
up to scratch in the intervening 9
months or so. In fact, they probably
intended to release it earlier, but then
in September, we had the start of the O
series of models from OpenAI. And then
in January, we got Deepseek R1. By the
way, if you want early access to my
fulllength documentary on Deep Seek and
R1, it's on my Patreon link in the
description. But I will say before we
completely write off Llama 4, as in this
meme, there is some solid progress that
it represents, especially the medium-siz
model, Llama 4 Maverick, as it compares
to the updated Deepseek V3. Both of
these models are, of course, not
thinking models like Gemini 2.5 or
Deepseek R1. Meta haven't released their
state-of-the-art thinking model yet, but
just bear in mind for a moment that for
all the halalu around DeepSeek V3, Llama
4 Maverick has around half the number of
active parameters and yet is comparable
in performance. Now, yes, I know people
accuse it of benchmark maxing or hacking
on LM Arena, but check out these real
numbers. Assuming none of the answers
made it into the training data for Llama
4, the performance of its models on GPQA
Diamond, the Google proof stem benchmark
that's extremely tough is actually
better than the new Deep Seek V3 or of
course GBC40. So if you were making the
optimistic case for Meta or for Llama 4,
you would say that they have a pretty
insane base model that they could create
perhaps a state-of-the-art thinking
model on top of. Only problem is Gemini
2.5 Pro is already there and Deepseek R2
is coming out any moment. Also, when you
take Llama 4 out of its comfort zone,
its performance starts to crater. Take
this coding benchmark, ADA's Polyglot
benchmark, testing model performance on
a range of programming languages. Unlike
many benchmarks, it doesn't just focus
on the Python programming language, but
a range of programming languages. And as
you can see, Gemini 2.5 Pro tops the
charts. Now, yes, you might say that's a
thinking model, but then look at Claude
3.7 Sonnet. That's without thinking. It
gets 60%. Deepseek v3, the latest
version gets 55%. And you unfortunately
have to scroll down quite far to get to
Llama 4 Maverick, which gets 15.6%. Now,
is it me or is performance like this
quite hard to square with headlines like
this one from Mark Zuckerberg, which is
that his AI models will replace
mid-level engineers soon? As in,
Zuckerberg says this year, 2025. Was he
massively hyping things out of all sense
of proportion? How dare you have that
thought? Four more quick things before
we leave Llama Fall. And yes, I did pick
that number deliberately. And the first
is on the tentative signs from their
biggest model, the unreleased one
behemoth. Now Meta have deliberately
made the comparisons with models like
Gemini 2 Pro and GPT 4.5 and the
comparison is somewhat favorable. Though
if you look closely at the footnotes, it
says Llama model results represent our
current best internal runs. Did they run
the model five times and pick the best
one? Three times? 10 times? We don't
know. Also note, they chose not to
compare Llama 4 Behemoth with Deepseek
V3, which is three times smaller in
terms of overall parameters and around
eight times smaller in terms of active
parameters. In dark blue, you can see
the performance of Deepseek V3, the
latest version. And you'd have to agree
it's pretty much comparable to Llama 4
Behemoth. In other words, if you wanted
to put a negative spin on the release,
you could say Llama's biggest model,
many times the size of the new Deep Seek
V3 base model, performs at the same
level basically. Now, yes, I know Llama
4 Behemoth is still quote in training,
but pretty much all models are quote in
training all the time at the moment with
post-training. Second, just a quick one
I saw halfway through the terms of use,
which is you're kind of screwed if you
are in the EU. You can still be the end
user of it. you just don't have the same
rights to build upon it. Next comes a
little nugget towards the bottom of the
page in which they've tried to make
Llama 4 lean a bit more right. They say
it's well known that LLMs have bias that
they historically lean left when it
comes to politics. So, they're going to
try to rectify that. I'm sure, of
course, that had nothing to do with
Zuckerberg's relationship to the new
administration. Finally, Simple Bench,
in which Llama 4 Maverick, the
medium-siz model, gets
27.7%, which is around the same level as
Deepseek V3. Now, that is a lower than
quote non-thinking models like 3.5
Sonnet that don't take that time to lay
out their chain of thought before
answering, but it's a solid performance.
Meta are definitely still in the race
when it comes to having great base
models upon which you can build
incredible reasoning models. Now, as it
happens, I did get some juicy hints
recently about what the performance of
03 would be on SimpleBench, and that's
the model coming in 2 weeks. I'll touch
on that in just a second. And let's just
say that it's going to be competitive. I
know that's kind of like an egregious
hint that I'm not backing up, but that's
all I can say at the moment. Now, what
you may have noticed in the middle of
the screen is that SimpleBench, which is
a benchmark you can check out in the
description. I created it around 9
months ago is powered by Weave from
Weights and Biases. They are sponsoring
this video and indeed the entire
benchmark as you can clearly tell with
the link at the center of the screen.
That will open up this quick start which
should be useful for any developer who
is interested in benchmarking language
models as we do to be honest. Even just
those who are interested in learning
more about LMS, you can check out the
Weights and Biases AI Academy down here.
As you can see, they are coming up with
new free courses pretty much all the
time. Now, I did say I'd mention the 03
news which came just a couple of days
ago from Sam Orman in which he told us
that 03 would be coming in about 2 weeks
from now. This is from my newsletter.
But do you remember when OpenAI and
Samman specifically said, "We want to do
a better job of sharing our intended
road map as we get closer to AGI. You
guys deserve clarity." Well, clarity
would be great because initially 03 was
supposed to come out shortly after 03
mini high which came out towards the end
of January. So naturally we expected it
in February. Then OpenAI did a 180 as
you can see in this tweet and someone
said we will no longer ship 03 as a
standalone model. Now, perhaps prompted
by the Gemini 2.5 Pro release, or their
GPUs melting because of everyone using
image gen, they've pushed back GPT 5 and
are now going to release 03 indeed as a
standalone model in 2 weeks. So, much
for clarity, then we're also apparently
going to get books about Samman's
misdeeds and dodgy documented behavior,
but that's a topic for another video.
One thing I bet OpenAI don't want us to
focus on is their new plans for their
nonprofit. Remember that 300 billion
valuation you saw earlier on in this
video? That depends on OpenAI becoming a
for-profit company. So, what's going to
happen to that nonprofit which was
supposed to control the proceeds of
OpenAI creating AGI? Remember, in the
slim chance that Samman is right and
OpenAI are the company that creates
trillions of dollars of value. As he
predicted, this nonprofit might have
ended up controlling trillions of
dollars worth of value. More
importantly, it would have controlled
what would have happened to AGI should
open AAI be the company that created it.
Now, put aside whether you think it will
be OpenAI that creates AGI or whether
AGI is even well- definfined or feasible
in the next 3 to 5 years. Just focus on
the promise that Sam Orman and OpenAI
made. We've gone from that nonprofit
controlling what could have been in
theory a significant fraction of the
world economy to supporting local
charities in California and perhaps
generously across America and beyond.
Now, hardly anyone, if anyone is
focusing on this story as OpenAI are no
longer the dominant players in the race
to AGI, but nevertheless, I think it's
significant. Now, if you are feeling
somewhat dehyped about AI after hearing
about Llama 4 and these OpenAI stories,
well, you could spend a few hours like I
did on the weekend reading
AI-2027. This was written by a former
OpenAI researcher and other super
forecasters with a pretty impressive
track record. Also, as you may remember,
Daniel Koko Tadelow put up an impressive
stand against OpenAI on their
non-disparagement clause. He was
essentially willing to forfeit millions
of dollars. And yes, you can make that
much as a safety researcher at OpenAI.
He was willing to forfeit that so he
wouldn't have to sign the
non-disparagement clause. Because he
made that stand, OpenAI were practically
forced into dropping that clause for
everyone. So well done him on that.
Nevertheless, I was not particularly
convinced by this report, even though I
admire the fact that they put dates on
the record for their predictions. To
honor that, I will try to match some of
their predictions with predictions of my
own. Their central premise in a nutshell
is that AI is first going to become a
superhuman coder and then ML researcher
and thereby massively speed up AI
progress, giving us super intelligence
in 2027. They draw fairly heavily on
this paper from meter. And I'm going to
cover that in a separate video because I
am corresponding fairly closely with one
of the key authors of that paper.
Anyway, we start off fairly lightly
basically with a description of what
current AI can do in terms of being an
agent like Chat GPT's operator and deep
research essentially describing what we
already have. We then get plenty of
detours into alignment and safety
because you sense the authors are trying
to get across that message at the same
time as making all of these predictions.
I start to meaningfully diverge from
their predictions when it comes to early
2026 when they say this. If China steals
the state-of-the-art AI, Agent One they
call it, weights, they could increase
their research speed by nearly 50%.
Based on all of the evidence you've seen
today about Deep Seek and Llama 4, you
would say it's almost equally likely
that the West will be stealing China's
weights. Or wait, they won't need to
because Deep Seek continue to make their
models open weight. Just like Leopold
Ashen Brena and Dario Ammedday,
everything is a race to the jugular,
which is a narrative that's somewhat
hard to square with Deep Seek pioneering
certain research and giving it to
everyone. Then apparently in late 2026,
the US Department of Defense will
quietly begin contracting OpenAI or
Google directly for cyber data analysis
and R&D. But I'm kind of confused
because already for at least a year,
OpenAI have been working directly with
the Pentagon. Yes, before you guys tell
me, I'm aware that Daniel Koko Tagelo,
who is the main author of this paper,
did make some amazing predictions back
in 2021 about the progress of AI. I can
link to that in the description, but
that doesn't mean he's going to be
always right going forward. Also, he
himself has admitted that those
predictions weren't that wide ranging.
Anyway, things get wild in January of
2027 because, as you can see from this
chart up here, we get an AI that is
better than the best human, the first
superhuman coder. In other words, this
is the key crux of the paper because
once you get that, you speed up AI
research and all the other consequences
follow. But as I have been discussing
with the authors of the meter paper,
there are so many other variables to
contend with. What about proprietary
code in Google or Meta or Amazon that
OpenAI can't train their models on? What
about benchmarks themselves being less
and less reliable indicators of real
world performance? Because the real
world is much messier than benchmarks.
This superhuman coder may need to liaz
with entire teams, get certain
permissions and pass all sorts of
hurdles of common sense. And even if you
wanted to focus brutally just on
verifiable benchmarks, not every
benchmark is showing an exponential.
Take MLE bench or machine learning
engineer bench from the deep research or
03 system card from OpenAI. That data
set consists of 75 handcurated Kaggle
competitions worth $2 million in prize
value. Measuring progress towards model
self-improvement is key to evaluating
autonomous agents full potential.
Basically, if models get good at machine
learning engineering, they can obviously
much more easily improve themselves. And
let's skip down to progress and zoom in
a bit. And you can see the performance
of 01, 03 mini, deep research without
browsing, deep research with browsing,
GPT40 even. And I'm not noticing an
absolute surge in performance.
Obviously, I am perfectly aware of
benchmarks like humanity's last exam and
others which are showing exponential
improvement. I'm just saying not every
benchmark is showing that. Also, January
or February of 2027 is less than 2 years
away. And this model would have to be
superhuman in performance. So much so
that it could autonomously develop and
execute plans to hack into AI servers,
install copies of itself, evade
detection, and use that secure base to
pursue whatever other goals it might
have. Notice the hasty caveat though.
How effectively it would do so as weeks
roll by is unknown and in doubt. That
happens a lot by the way in the paper. I
even noticed a co-author say, "Well,
this wasn't my prediction. It was
Daniels." There's a lot of kind of heavy
caveing of everything. Notice though
that not only would an AI model have to
be superhuman at coding to do all of
this, it would have to have very few if
any major flaws. if one aspect of its
proposed plan wasn't in its training
data or it couldn't do it reliably, the
whole thing would fail. And that leads
me to my prediction. I mean, they've
made a prediction, so I can make one
that models even by 2030 will not be
able to do this. I'm talking reliably
with 95 or 99% reliability,
autonomously, fully autonomously,
develop execute plans to hack into AI
servers, copy itself, evade detection,
etc. If on the other hand, Daniel is
right and models are capable of this by
February 2027, then I will admit I am
wrong. That by the way brings me back to
this chart, which if you notice says
that only 4% of people at that point
would say, "What do you think is the
most important problem facing the
country today?" And they'd answer AI.
Well, I don't know about you, but if I
or my friends or family heard that
there's AI out there that just can hack
things and replicate itself and survive
in the wild, I think more than 4% of
people would say it's the most important
issue. I mean, man, actually, the more I
think of it, like look at the clickbait
headlines you get on YouTube and
elsewhere about AI today. Can you
imagine the clickbait if AI was actually
capable of copying itself onto different
servers and hacking autonomously?
Actually, it wouldn't even be clickbait
at that point. I would be doing
headlines like, "Oh my god, it can hack
everything." Anyway, you get the idea.
And that's not even mentioning the fact
that these agents can also almost as
well as a human pro create bioweapons
and the rest of it. China is then going
to steal that improved agent 2 from the
Pentagon and still obliviously 96% of
people are focused on other things.
Being slightly less facitious, I think
the paper overindexes on weight thefts
and it all being contained in the
weights of a model. I think progress
between now and 2030 is going to much
more depend on what data you have
available, what benchmarks you have
created, what proprietary data you can
get a hold of. Now, don't get me wrong,
I do think AI will help with the
improvement of AI, even if it's just
verifying and evaluating replicating
existing AI research, which is a new
benchmark released by OpenAI just a week
ago. Already models like Claude 3.5
Sonet can replicate 21% of the papers in
this benchmark. But when you have
limited compute and potentially very
limited compute if there's a massive
worldwide stock crash or war in Taiwan,
but when you have limited compute, are
you going to delegate the decision of
which avenues to pursue to a model which
might be only 80% as good as your best
researchers? No, you would just defer to
those top researchers. Only when a model
was making consistently better decisions
than your best researchers as to how to
deploy compute would you then entrust it
to them. The authors definitely bring in
some real world events that may or may
not have occurred at OpenAI when they
say AI safety sympathizers get sidelined
or fired outright brackets the last
group for fear that they might
whistleblow. Personally, I would predict
that if we have an autonomous AI that
can hack and survive on its own, I don't
think safety sympathizers will be
sidelined. If I am wrong, then we as a
human species are a lot dumber than I
thought. Anyway, just 2 years from now,
June 2027, most of the humans at
OpenAI/G Google can't usefully
contribute anymore. Again, I just don't
think feedback loops can happen that
quickly when you reach this level. I
could well imagine benchmarks like the
MMU or simple bench being maxed out at
this point. But imagine you're trying to
design a more aerodynamic or efficient
F47. That's the new fighter jet
announced by the Pentagon. Well, that AI
self-improvement is going to be
bottlenecked by the realism of the
simulation that it's benchmarking
against. Unless that simulated aircraft
exactly matches the real one, well, then
you won't know if that quote
self-improving AI has indeed improved
the design unless you test it out in a
real aircraft. Then multiply that
example by the 10,000 other domains in
which there's proprietary data or sim to
real gaps. I guess you could summarize
my views as saying the real world is a
lot more messy than certain isolated
benchmarks online. The model, by the
way, at this point is plausibly
extremely dangerous, being able to
create boweapons and is scarily
effective at doing so, but 92% are
saying it's not the most important
issue. Man, how good would Tik Tok have
to get so that 92% of people wouldn't be
focused on AI at that point? I'm going
to leave you with the positive ending of
the two endings given by the paper which
predicts this in 2030. We end with
people terraform and settle the solar
system and prepare to go beyond. AIs
running at thousands of times subjective
human speed reflect on the meaning of
existence, exchanging findings with each
other. That's helpful. And shaping the
values it will bring to the stars. A new
age dawn, one that is unimaginably
amazing in almost every way, but more
familiar in some. Those in the audience
with a higher PDOM can check out the
other scenario, which is rather grim.
Notice though, I'm not disputing whether
some of these things will happen, just
the timelines that they give. I still
think we're living in some of the most
epo times of all, just that it might be
a more epoch decade rather than couple
of years. Thank you as ever for
watching. I know I covered a lot in one
video. I will try to separate out my
videos more in future. I'm super proud
of the Deep Sea documentary I made on
Patreon. So, do check it out if you want
early access. art regardless.